okay four people joining the livestream
we are reviewing numerical computation
functionality for the upcoming version
of Wolfram language so is this mainly
about optimization Roger
well wallets for Roger
yes it's mainly about optimization but I
think we should actually do that no no
no no I don't think we should Rob I
believe because I think ill divert us so
yes it's really about optimization and I
wish where we should focus the bulk of
our work today or all of our work and
then there's a small thing at the end
that's another topic which is something
required for differential equations okay
okay so and can I just I'll just talk
through a little bit here in the
beginning to get us going it yep so this
is what we've added is several classes
of convex optimization problems these
are a little bit specialist functions
but they are in fact integrated into
fine minimum and and minimize and those
twelve functions it means new that
that's happened that's new that that's
happened so to give a little bit of
background it the old classification of
optimization problems usually talks
about linear and nonlinear optimization
starting in around late 80s and the 90s
it sort of became clear that there were
new vistas of very efficient classes of
optimization problems that can be sold
fast both in theory and in practice and
you might recall things like Kumar's
algorithm right in the mid 80s that did
for linear programming that got
generalized to convex optimization you
can in fact get polynomial time
algorithms for convex optimization
problem and it's sort of well understood
when you can get that or what it's
required to get to that so the new
classification is convex and non convex
optimization meaning that that means the
polyhedron the polytope that defines the
the conditions is convex so what that
means yes so we have two constraint if
you have only linear constraint that
defines the polyhedron it's might be an
unbounded polyhedron you know but it
still comebacks and it doesn't matter
for operation whether its bounded or
unbounded yup and
but these are many more classes of
things that if you're able to formulate
your problem as a convex optimization
problem you can credibly say that it's
solved if you just formulated there's an
optimization problem you cannot usually
mm-hmm
sure I'm saying sir sorry for the
polyhedra and polygons we just looked at
do we do it
so don't finish it sorry no we don't
okay are we planning to we are planning
to so we're gonna have to have more
unbounded regions okay so the
generalized case for a polyhedron Steven
is dead and this if you take a convex
polyhedron a convex polyhedron is
actually the Minkowski sum or the sum of
a convex hull which is the part and
what's called a conic hull these raised
to infinity yep
and so yes we're gonna come to that
we have a little bit now in the in the
we have unbounded regions already in the
region framework but more generally for
meshes in polyhedral and so on okay and
yeah but why don't
a little bit and now we'll fill in kind
of go what are we going to the guide
page for complex optimization
yes it's a good place to start now these
functions what they provide are two ways
to give the problems and they output
they provide I'm gonna which is that
there's several things to cover your sin
so we live with a chanel basically
examples by the way no it has is just
it's closed oh okay but the examples
need another round okay they're not
there you know you shouldn't treat them
as final and these are certainly not the
way they will look hmm
the application examples I think a
rather good at this point
but basic scope and properties need are
not around I think the applications are
really quite impressive it will give you
more than you would take get in a
typical class on linear optimization and
similar for the only other classes what
do we have we have that function for
find what is that that's a packing
function right what is it called the one
that what is that function called you
know I'm talking about where you're
trying to find a
it's effectively a packing a knapsack
function right well we have we have a
bin packing function right or yes I'm
sorry
Maxo problem or something so those are
very specialized optimization problem
now that one is a particular class of
what's called combinatorial optimization
sure but what I'm just trying to
understand is what's the correspondence
and the syntax between all these various
things
well this follows optimization
conventions so I haven't looked at
though specialized function can have all
kinds of specialized syntax so I
understand that but so these are general
purpose functions but not as general
purposes fine minimum and n minimize
obviously but the one thing one thing
that they do provide what these
functions can provide is is also
information on the dual
so for each optimization problem there's
something called the Lagrangian dual and
this is this provides a different way of
solving a problem but it also provides
something called sensitivity so for
instance let's say you minimize some big
problem it has you know a thousand
constraints what happens if I relax one
other constraints give it more resources
how much better would the optimum be yep
that's something people are super
interested in for obvious reasons mm-hmm
and for the class of convex optimization
we can actually do that and it's very
valuable information so we don't have
another function that's called dual
linear optimization but the dual problem
is provided in all these problems the
dual information that's what those
things down below there is what so is
there a minimal version of what I can
call to get to run linear optimization
yes
so unfortunately these early problems
use the coefficients in text if you put
it it's it's we also support the
variables so I'm saying you can actually
give symbolic constraints and that's
easier and we haven't updated these
basic examples which I is unfortunate
because okay all right so fine so but if
I were to give this so I'm just cutting
say X plus y okay you can just do
symbolic this you can understand what
the heck you do okay all right I was
then say you know X minus y greater than
one yeah greater no one and then X plus
y less than two or something like that
ten an income I X comma Y
well that's that's good it will actually
return plus infinity or minus infinity
as appropriate but why is it saying that
this problem is unbounded which means it
means that the minimum will be Adam and
the minimum actually is minus infinity
okay well this problem is definitely
solvable yes and that gives you that
point okay so there are other things I
can ask for from this optimization yes
so if you go to that list to scroll up
stop there so primal minimizer it's what
it returns normally right so I didn't
know that okay so like the duality gap
which I've never heard of by the way
it's not water completing here so and
win that duality gap and this is a very
this called strong duality it means that
the dual problem has actually the same
optimal solution as the primal problem
there's no gap okay and that means that
you know one way to solve it is to solve
the dual problem and from the two of
them you get a bunch of you know
okay
okay cool
all right so and this is now an
industrial-strength object is that right
yes but there's another caveat here so
what we've been doing we are currently
using and we haven't been writing any
new solvers
okay so what we've been doing is to make
use of solvers that people have
developed over quite a long time
good solvers that are available what we
plan to do for 12:1 is also to provide
standard IP is API so that you can use
if you buy commercial solvers from
places like mosaic guro b/c plaques and
these places they will plug in and you
can still use our modeling framework
from fine minimum and minimize and you
know is there a reasonable API to these
guys have reasonable api's we think so
we've looked at one too we think that
they all have it because that's their
business and and so what is it doing
it's running there's a process running I
mean is it being started by start
process so how does it work but we don't
run it right now we've planned to no I
understand I mean is the idea that it is
a WS TP connection or is the idea that
it's a start process run on the command
line type in well we haven't gone there
it probably needs to your library
integration it needs to be fast they're
gonna transfer a lot of data certainly W
STP probably won't cut it
okay so it's a it's okay
so this partnerships probably needs to
be involved exactly that's a partnership
do you know the whole thing is a
partnership thing we turn these faith
these companies into partners instead of
competitors all right
um okay and we might write solvers in
the future but I think what we've added
so what's here is is a it's a massive
amounts of stuff that deals with
transforming problems into these
standard classes and between classes and
so there's there's a lot of libraries
here that underpins it but we have a the
framework that makes it use work much
more broadly than how they narrowly
define here is the transformation
framework so we've had a function called
linear programming forever how does that
relate to these things okay so we are
going to but not now I think that the
correct thing is to obsolete that and do
a linear programming so first of all
this notion of call it programming is a
notion from the 1950s or 40s okay now
the whole community is changing away
from programming they renamed their
societies to become societies of
optimization instead of programming
courses
everything is moving away from the
detailed programming because it's it
means something different they lost it
that word they lost that word okay so we
are with the new wave it's the idea okay
but so I understand the C a B here
mmm how does that relate to the CMB here
well you can just follow the text and
you can see it it's M M is a and B as -
be lovely okay and these other things
here are somehow also supported is that
right right there's one thing we need to
do before we can obsolete it and that is
to do integer programming right exactly
okay an idea is that we will generally
do integer and mixed real and integer
for all of these problem classes and so
in the constraints will say elements of
integers and things or what how it makes
pussified yes
well fair enough okay but that's another
that'sthat's another step you see to
actually these convex optimization
problems they'd have an amazing property
let's say you solve it over the reals
hmm
you just round it you can actually get
the bound from the dual that tells you
how bad off your approximation is so you
know how far away you are from optimum
in the worst case right that's an
amazing property of these guys and so
okay little list just solve the correct
to solve it correctly you know with
integer mixed integer there's a this
there's real work that needs to be done
so I don't quite understand I mean when
you give these things with constraints
and so on I mean other than just knowing
oh that's a quadratic programming
problem or that's a conic programming
problem um how I mean what uses it to
the user to have all these different
functions can I answer that one Roger I
think that's a really good question
Stephen and that the the real use in
these functions I mean if if somebody
just wants to get the minimum they
should use n minimize or find minimum
okay done problem solved easy if they
want information based on the dual and
more details of the problem they should
be solvers and these solvers provide
different slightly different you know
ways of presenting the dual solution
that is useful in particular types of
situations okay also if you're writing a
program that's gonna call a problem
class programmatically that probably
means it's sort of a high performance
kind of you know situation you want to
be guaranteed that it hits the right
problem class we'd guaranteed
performance that's much easier to manage
this these lower level functions then
the higher level one all right so I mean
with the exponential cone is irrelevant
for linear optimization assume is your
point
I don't know what yes it can't be used
it can only be used in in chronic
optimization the only one that can
handle that that particular type of
input okay um okay well I yeah
all right let's look at these constructs
here I mean is that unless I might wait
no I mean it-it's just it's it's lower
level but one thing if you just want to
look at something if you look in their
application there is a subsection under
each application that says problem
transformations with standard problem
transformations okay basic modeling
transformations okay we have one of
those for each and that tells you how
you map a variety of problems into this
problem class okay I think it's more for
expert use but that's the kind of thing
you would learn if you if you're serious
about optimization okay so let me take
this example you pick the hardest case
Steven conic optimization is the most
sophisticated of it okay so you're
optimizing what does this mean okay so
this is what's use what it uses there is
called an epigraph transformation what's
even the statement of the problem well
it was don't text it was there in the
text for the example that you looked at
okay that's the objective function T yes
so now you're gonna minimize T okay but
we really wanted to minimize the
absolute value of x plus y okay so you
see how this transformed it you added a
new variable T and that t minus T and T
bounds X plus y okay okay but that's the
same as saying that you're gonna
minimize you know absolute value of x
plus y okay so if I were to say find
minimum or should I be using and
minimize either either should work fine
what happens if I use minimize well it
will work too but it will use not
efficient this is only numerical
algorithms okay all right and minimize
okay so you're saying I'm really trying
to get abs of what X plus y minimize
that subject to the constraint okay but
we have you have to have another level
of brace around the two pairs sorry this
this is that thing with a constraint
that XY is an element of a disc right
and that can actually just be the
variable declaration friend minimize as
well you want to you need to use the
disc they provided that's not that
doesn't include the zero point okay okay
so did this use the same code path as
this essentially yes so if I were to go
for example um how do I get an N
dimensional ball oh I just put a bunch
of things in that right so if I say
table 1 comma 6
oh god how do I do this but you can you
could just use acts as a single vector
variable and I don't know this is gonna
work because I don't know if we have
ball hooked up for and then you do total
of ABS of X no absolute total of ABS of
X right total of ABS facts yeah sorry
I would seem to get there so with one of
it what's that yes which I found you
this yes deuce do send me that um okay
do you think it got the right answer
who knows well anyway it doesn't matter
but but um okay but so this in principle
works and in its feeding itself into
potentially I mean I'm just trying to
understand these code parts this this
thing is feeding itself into this same
so to what extent from and minimize can
I reach all of the all of the default
property features of these various
special solvers no okay no you can't get
the dual and things like that because I
said the default property that is that
that is not not the special not the
stuff that I see okay yes so if the so
here's the thing if it's recognized okay
in minimize or find a minimum then it
will use those same code paths they say
I'll tell you how I did the code path
for this statement so what what end
minimize does is it it it consists so
I've sort of set up a structure that
holds what I call an optimization
problem okay and that's that's how all
of these Hamlet's all those are the
handles what end minimize does is a
construction one of these constructs it
tries to do the transformations which
gets it into one of these solver forms
if it succeeds in doing those
transformation it calls the solver okay
and if the solver succeeds
end of story it's done yep otherwise it
goes back to the to the the other method
that the default methods end minimize
always used to have or
if somebody specifically specifies some
method then it will use that method
obviously right okay sounds great all
right let's go and look at these unless
there's more stuff we should look at I
mean I don't think I can be very helpful
with all those dual unless they're
naming issues with all those do or
whatever things I don't think so no
nothing about that stuff um I never
heard of primal values before sounds
well it's sort of an optimization II
type thing they talk about the primal
problem in the dual problem
what does dual problem mean it it is a
related so it comes from Lagrange
multipliers if you remember those yes
okay in the solver pages we have a
little explanation of what the dual
problem is it's this general for all of
these all right okay um by the way
okay so first people are asking various
questions on the live stream let's
address those before we go on here one
is asking for can we add one of the
following optimization methods three
pars an estimator I've never heard of
this Gaussian process surrogate or
random forest regression okay we should
send them in that's not the project
we're doing now optimization is a wild
in and diverse diverse field and so dose
or none of those have any reliable
performance characteristics right yes
it doesn't mean that they don't work
they have problem classes over which
they work great mom random forests we
are using extensively in machine
learning yes I mean that's supported by
classifier and things like that but is
that that's not here no I understand but
is there any interplay between what
classify the way we got a bunch of weird
background noise yeah so a lot of these
things the standard application example
we have for each of them
to solve classification problems and
fitting problems and so on those are
standard kind of fare problems right but
so so I guess I'm asking the question
okay so those are problems like fitting
um um let's see the so things like
fitting which eventually become things
like quadratic optimization problems and
so on if I'm not mistaken are we also
sort of using these new solvers for
those or not okay so two of two answers
there one is that we actually have here
updates to find fit and fit yet useless
that extends them to support what's
called regularization let's talk about
that a little later you know as we work
our way down the page so we have updates
there and then we have a much larger set
of updates planned for twelve one in
terms of seating all the in-house teams
with solutions using this new technology
so that applies to almost all teams and
we'll see that start to kick out in
function all across our system
okay
all right okay so these vector
inequality so there's two things a the
way the reason we introduced them here
is that they provide a modeling
framework they provide ways to write you
know optimization constraints using
vector variables and there what what the
hell is that what just happen there well
this is an old page
unfortunately I mean it's not an old
page but that is probably not the
correct
I mean not clip you know I'd say you've
got an all build from yesterday well
let's say vector greater equal let's
just say vector greater equal X Y okay
doesn't hang open so now you actually
need to have a list brace around those
two
Stephen you need to actually put them in
a yeah in a list those yeah why okay
I'll come to that in a second
okay okay so and so the core motivation
is this allows you to formulate a lot of
these problem cleanly and you get sort
of a high level and fairly efficient
language to formulate them the other
thing is that these vector inequalities
are quite fundamental in that this is
the class of the partial orders they're
not total orders that's that's why
they're not sort of overloading you know
less equal and so on
and so you can have they can return
false
you know either because they
okay so there's some other condition
here that that subscript Kappa yes okay
so the point is that this is the class
of all possible vector inequalities that
are also compatible with a vector space
structure that means that if you have an
inequality X greater than equal to Y and
then you can add a vector Z on both
sides and it's still true yes and you
can multiply the left and right hand
side with positive numbers and it's
still true if you enforce that and it
almost everything in scientific
computing technical computing relies on
a vector space if you enforce that they
are necessarily defined by a convex cone
a proper convex cone okay so now you can
have other kinds of inequalities you
know the default case is just like X is
greater than equal to Y if X 1 is
greater than Y 1 and X 2 is greater than
Y 2 but for instance for matrices you
can have the space of positive semi
definite matrices and one matrix is then
greater than another if their difference
is a positive semi definite matrix
okay oh and that space of pasta
semi-definite matrices that is a cone
that is a proper convex cone so it
defines a proper you know inequality
something something is horribly gone
wrong with the typesetting well the
parsing as well yeah the parting of the
the parsing of the typeset what what's
the precedence of that operator that's a
good question
Inc if ETA was here he could immediately
answer that what should it be and by the
way did was it put in the syntax table
if it hasn't been it will be shortly and
likewise the character pages will be put
in shortly okay but well I mean I meant
the syntax table that has been you know
I understand but prominently that used
to be in the appendix of the book right
it's a good good reminder we need to get
it there obviously but the question what
what should its precedents be rolling it
should be relatively close to a writer
inequalities should it be Coe I mean I
think the other inequalities yeah I mean
the other inequalities have this strange
property right that if you say X greater
than or equal to y greater than Z yes
that thing turns into that so I want to
return to inequality but not now but
very soon so we can sort that out once
and forever because stetson and it's
sort of needed but it's undocumented
right so we have a similar construct for
these these vector inequalities and it's
called it's set up as developer vector
inequality but we have rules so that
basically always evaluates to either
inequality which once we deal with that
that'll be great or the individual
vector vector greater or equal etcetera
etcetera but so so how do those I don't
quite understand because you have to
have a three argument if you say a
greater than B greater than C right so
that means that in that list there there
are multiple that there are several
things right yes you can have several
things there you can have any number of
any number of of things to compare with
the same operator there
right so by the way the fact that you're
giving this may by the way I you really
really should give in the in the usage
message you should give the typed out
form of these as well but less we we
probably should let you know greater
equal doesn't okay you never see that
that form is not available anywhere okay
well perhaps it should be but but but
this one is much more obscure because
somebody's gonna look at this they're
not gonna see the little squiggly you
know I agree Flair right I think you're
right right well that's what the table
two down is supposed to do yes Sandra on
a live stream hopefully points out you
can just do that
mmm
that does not look right to me that does
not look right at all yeah other a
Sandra live stream also points out that
this answer is correct you can despite
the complaining okay thank you sander
it's still a bad it's it's okay so this
is wrong yeah I think we need to look at
that but but look at the you know in the
part I mean there was a lot of things
wrong there in this build no I
understand that
so I'm asking this question when you
type this in does it really support
subscript in the operator because I
don't think we support that for anything
else yes eat I set it up so that it
indeed supports subscripting you can you
can subscript or under script the
operator and it's they're both supported
incredibly exotic okay why don't we
support that in a bunch of operators
some supports it product supports it int
integrate supports it partial D laminate
subscript yeah how else do you type
these things in in typeset form
oh you mean I I see I submit but the
mail okay the in its exotic for an infix
operator
what other infix operator does that well
I don't know if we have any I'm I'm
listen I would like to sound a concern
about it because I don't know how that's
supposed to work and I have a bad
feeling something might go wrong with it
no no but this part of why we have the
extra level a list there because then is
structurally possible I mean a lot of
concerns with parsing we're addressed
the cherem saying yeah
hey by the way or not live stream
someone is asking about had asked before
about some better ways of distributing
numerical optimization across large AWS
compute instances for example that's
that's again not something we've looked
at now I don't agree with that that's a
that's a that's a valuable thing to do
it's a different kind of project
fair enough I mean obviously if you just
get a very big crunchy computer you're a
server computer you can run this I don't
even know how how do these parallel
lines across do these parallel eyes well
in in parallel environments I've not
heard of that I mean you know in other
words when I hear about like the giant
you know airline optimization stuff of
old I thought that was just on done on
one very big computer I didn't think it
was done in parallel do these algorithms
parallel eyes I don't know um it's it's
another project to look into I think if
it's if it's if it's reasonably doable
to make them parallel eyes Apple then
then the commercial solvers will have
done that and when we hook up for these
commercial solvers we should be able to
make that available a lot of these
things to parallel eyes they do it
because they did they don't really work
that well so you need to kind of start
from multiple points or you need to
there's other ways to break the problem
to that you update this part here you
update this outer part here you come
together then you have an updated state
then you move from there it's it's
um
yeah okay
well anyway
that's the future okay again I strongly
believe for this particular operator
it's very important to say up above here
vector greater equal or this funky form
okay makes sense yes yes yes
okay so I have no clue what any of this
stuff means okay so and this was a pivot
we did last week we first had these
cones as actual objects in the system we
decided that they didn't warrant that
today now just these forms and if you
look at the first one that's the
non-negative cone that's the standard
vector greater equal because look at the
second input form up there at the top
and the ground box the
that X is greater than or equal to Y
it's the same as that the difference is
in that cone okay I understand okay but
that's exactly how the cone and
conversely if you have one of these and
all it is defined they actually define a
count but why do you need that n that
presumably you can just see what they
dimension of the what the length of
those vectors is I'm presumably can just
say non-negative cone yes you can so you
should document that oh you do okay but
so for this for norm cone can you also
do that yes surely you can because it
knows what what you know which are n
you're talking about by just blowing
through the vectors right if you've
specified the length of the vector
elsewhere you know if it's a symbolic
vector and you don't touch the
components of it's not a list okay I say
an X if you've specified a length
elsewhere
or other parts of the problem uniquely
define that length sure no numeric is
hyphenated there's a trivial fact for
you okay okay all right what else should
I pay attention to in these functions I
think that's it you know they they will
come into play there's a there's a large
number of other areas that much broader
in the system we've currently integrated
them they also work for a symbolic
optimization function they work for um
you know reduce solve all of these
things can now take these specs it means
that you can also integrate using bool
and other things kind of work sweeties
they are in fact very useful to specify
multivariate conditions of various kinds
I won't go into that now but it's it's
it's a whole slew of things that you
should check that knapsack function to
make sure that it's not insanely and
consistent with what we've got here I I
will but as I said I don't really care
about these special solvers because they
don't solve general problems yeah I
understand but we should make sure that
from the point of view of the
design but it's not incompatible sure
let's just find out what that function
actually is just a second I should
remember it we took a long time naming
it that what was finally called that was
the most obvious name okay
yeah see this one specifies you know in
a way yeah it's it's very specialized
how this is formula enough so I wonder
if there's anything to learn from this
use of an association here I mean like
when you have categorical there I think
I think if you're not so if you're not
giving sort of a general optimization
problem or if you're doing something
more special that's focused on one
particular application domain like this
sure because that's you're gonna give
basically a bunch of data various kinds
and that's agnostic it outrageous
question how are we doing with units
support for these things
I think optimization functions generally
support units right really
find a minimum doesn't support units
I don't know you tell me I don't know so
are you telling me if I say this and I
say quantity here no but that's not an
optimization function that's what I
understand okay but I think greater than
supports units right bet it does
that's cool okay do you think factor
greater recall does this - no I don't
think so okay it could it could easily
do but I don't think it does right okay
fine I don't well I think that's just a
that's just a restriction I put on the
code that so one of these st. one of the
things these things don't do is they
don't evaluate and this is really
important is they don't they don't
evaluate if any of the inputs or
symbolic so probably my restriction of
symbolic caches quantity which you
should not do okay okay okay okay
wonderful all right should we look at
the I mean that's great that that okay
so bool I'm just saying that so if I
integrate the bool you know you can give
want to integrate sort of over there
first orphans or something like that so
if I say vector greater X Y comma well
let me just understand something so if I
say vector greater X comma 1 1 for
example and then I say well if I were to
just say region plot of that X element
no ok so there's there's a different
restriction I just found out - ok the
region plot and region plot 3d doesn't
support region argument in the second
case in the in the
Jim saying that exeunt a disk is not
supported okay we allowed that but this
so that's that's it completed it's a
different missing feature if you see it
science but if you do explicit X comma Y
in in a list yeah I'm just in it rare
yeah that so then it's a different story
but
yeah okay fine that's slightly useful
for understanding what these vector
thingies are how do I see something be a
cone or something or be a another so
vector greater if I say dual exponential
cone not having any idea what it is
right so that's a 3d thing first of all
oh okay well can I try um a normed cone
yeah fascinating well it seems like a
useful example for the for the
documentation if you don't read it right
if you if you use vector less equal if
you look at the application example it's
a little bit more filled in but this
over the next week or two there's
several more things coming in but if you
go back to less equal look at the
applications you'll see a variety of
things
okay why did I mean that little squiggly
you know sort of broken nose there thing
whatever it is is that just a numerical
error yes okay and how would I get it to
not have that you had a problem with
region plot or is that a problem with
vector crater it's a problem with region
plot and so you need to have just more
points than region plot that's fine
right okay okay that's cool um so if I
were to say region plot 3d I could see
one of these fancy do a residential
cones
yes actually go to vector less equal and
you have a whole gallery of them okay
okay so now if you go to either
properties or applications they're
starting to be more this is because of a
pivot so if you look here there you see
the gallery of cones basically okay cool
and okay and this is this is you know
you can see it's not quite updated
because these are the objects that we've
decided not to introduce there's going
to be string sister
I see that's a power cone with a certain
exponent for its norm there or something
yes okay very nice all right let's go
back to the agenda um now there are okay
this is talking about the future
we've talked a little bit about it
already
what's the machine learning play with
these things well so this this is gonna
be increasing things but one thing right
now Rob why don't you talk about that
sure I've contacted Etienne and I've
looked at some of the some of the basics
like the linear layer stuff they have
and you know trying to figure out what
they've done basically with the new
stuff I've put into fitting we have you
know from faster to orders of magnitude
faster than what they're currently using
for that and I'm hoping to talk to him
when I'm in Champaign next week you know
to see what other possibilities there
are but that's just one one clear
example that of well right now it's
using some kind of you know steepest
descent back propagation thing to Seoul
yeah and there's a so in the in the new
fit there's a really interesting method
for doing this these basis pursuit type
problems that that that I put together
is based on sort of sequential doing
quadratic optimization multiple times
and it's really fast okay and it can it
can handle huge huge huge basis problems
and the code they have now it would just
you know completely bogged down with
that sort of thing
okay well it's great all right let's
just very quick look at whatever you
were doing in nonlinear PDEs here it's
big news the big actual feature is that
we now support nonlin solving nonlinear
PDEs
over arbitrary regions so it is
basically a finite element but for
nonlinear PDEs that's impressive
okay okay and
one thing that we need is the one thing
the one symbol that we need to introduce
is a starting guess and it's it turns
out that there is a it's it's it came up
in this project when you have nonlinear
PDEs and you specify boundary problems
it's not necessarily a unique solution
there are multiple possible solutions
don't we have this in like a million
places like even in fine minimum or
something we've got an X sub zero that
we're specifying and they they're in the
variable in the collect you know in the
specification of the variable you're
right okay so and the question is should
you start making that prob you know part
of the problem specification and in it
and if we without without going out to
optimization right away so just think of
differential equations mm-hmm boundary
value problems in general have this
feature that they're more than one
solution whatever happened to our
vaunted PD special function effort you
know the Helmholtz equation get it
getting in actual you know like like
just but the [ __ ] killed Helmholtz
equation we can return to that Steven
but the boundary conditions is gonna be
massive okay but still I have to
remember how to type in a I know I know
so we gonna you know what part of we
want to do is to have more special
operators and we could still do two
special functions case with special
operators means you know the heat right
and we and that's our gold okay that's
to to to do that modeling project it's
gonna make it easier for everybody to do
the modeling side of these PDS yep
but but but going back to starting guess
okay so boundary value problems is a
typical thing that you have multiple
solutions in the question which one are
you picking out there's another case
which is when you have these over
constrained systems if you like it's
almost impossible to find a consistent
initial condition in fact that's a
massive part of what the system modular
product salts to find initial condition
because these di es you're on some
manifold that's much lower dimensional
than the number of variables that you
have what's your chance of hitting that
right mom probability 0 right so you
need some help
in fact built into the Metallica
standard even that their defense things
are interpreted as initial guesses and
we have had kind of hockey method things
to do this before but I think that the
proper way is to indicate it as part of
the problem statement of where you start
yeah
another point is that that unlike so
five minimum has this this specialized
thing for giving the starting guests
with the variable that's sort of an
awkward syntax and look of documentation
is sort of hard to figure out
listen indie solve what we typically do
and this is your design I think was a
good idea is we the the specification
for sort of the dependent variables is
done automatically so basically the
third argument for nd solve where's the
second argument I Kimber which is
actually what you want to want to have
as output or like ending some value okay
so we're not we don't actually
necessarily even always specify what the
dependent variables are on our live
stream even black 86 points out that MX
net already uses fast solvers so and
also makes it the general purpose gem
system is still under the two point nine
three I see there okay so it may not be
this it may be that once the linear
layer is inside MX net it's going very
fast maybe yeah obviously so one thing
that that you can do with a specialized
layered software stack like MX net is
that you I mean you have to do things
like algorithmic differentiation in
order to compute the gradients all the
way you know through the layers and
that's you know and but they
also pushed optimization technology they
push first order methods a lot because
you can't compute second derivatives
it's usually too hard we don't have five
million parameters it's it's hard
alright let's go back to Scotland
starting guess ok so I mean we really
don't want to introduce something like
this at this stage in the development
cycle this is a big complicated thing
that will have effects on lots of
functions lots of functions you know
find instance there are just tons and
tons of things I also am very unclear
that this is the right semantics for it
as opposed to an option I understand
there are scoping issues with an option
hmm we really should not introduce this
right now what what is it needed for
right now it's needed for a nonlinear
PDEs look this okay then then we should
change it another meeting to talk about
this because this is not a 2 minute
question I mean this is sure we'll do
you know III think no we'll do that it's
fine it's a very weird piece of
semantics it is slightly weird but let's
think about how it relates to for
example when event which is another
weird piece of semantics in an equation
setting hmm I mean it's it's not
directly related but I mean what this is
is it's telling you this is a thing that
only matters
transiently in looking at the equation
so in other words it's as if it's sort
of like a when event which is just add a
like a delta function at T equals zero
if I'm not mistaken her words or isn't
it even it isn't even that it's not even
this isn't even a value this is not
something that actually occurs for the
variables in the equation this is merely
an advisory thing for you know oh you're
trying to solve this boundary value
problem the value of Phi might be
such-and-such is that correct that's
correct so it's yes it's an advisory for
an algorithm that that the the solver
may eventually use so most of those
things we would do in options yes okay
so what's the reason to not have this be
an option well if you want to so so so
one Ahriman is yes you could have this
you could have this down you know down
as a as a type of type of method or
option forget method I mean it's just
just a regular option where it says you
know starting guesses arrow and then you
know for arrow expo or bar equals equals
x bar could be could be that okay so the
reason that i already said is is that
there is a scoping question with that
but i don't know how seriously we're
scoping these these equations solving
how are we scoped in what are we doing
with a scoping of something like linear
optimization and the question okay so
none of the convex solvers need initial
values there's no starting guesses
that's in fact the phase of the
optimization problem to find an initial
point and you know they don't need them
Roger but they can be they can be given
that wasn't the point I was making the
point I was making was a purely
structural point we've got variables
here
xyt so so Steven it is scoped
mathematically speaking it's not scoped
if you think of programmatic scoping
okay fine I'm saying so it's not a whole
doll thing it's it's we have many things
that are mathematically scope but not
programmatic no I understand so I think
what this should be you know you know I
don't see any reason you don't you know
we can go down that route I think that's
the right way to do it go you know apart
from scoping this seems like the right
level of stuff but I don't know whether
you want to call it gas what are we
calling it in the case of final minimum
for example what do we refer to it in
the documentation as starting values but
see that's that's really problematic in
a dde setting because because starting
values have a meaning because that's an
independent variable that might write
okay anyway the the I just initial guest
just seems like an awfully informal
thing to say what would be well we have
fancier name for this well the reason we
came up with initial guesses we tried
all sorts of different names is because
there's something there's something
guests in the medela calanque
is sort of a it is if we want her to
avoid starting value or initial value
because no it's about I do it's a bad
idea right well look I think I'm by the
way
can you please report this bug that I've
mentioned many times that the cursor is
not turning into a vertical eyeball
okay I mean it was something more like
that right it's like assumptions but
that that implies you really assuming
something about I know I know it isn't
correct I mean I think that guesses is
not as because really it it doesn't it
if it has nothing except except in the
sense of algorithm it actually has
nothing mathematically to do with the
solution
well okay so we could do I mean actually
doesn't need to be plural right what is
it it's a solution gasps it's it's it's
really initial value guess initial value
is it a salon well it depends yes
so for deep furred for different jobs or
both equations it's it's a guess
on the initial values for stationery
PDEs
it's it's a guess on the solution but
does it typically look like f of 0 is
whatever is that what it's typically
like yes or f of X is whatever okay
and why is it so it's an initial guess
because it may be ignored that's right
it may it may be ignored
is it a guest for the solution or is it
a guest for something else it's it's
it's it's a guess for either the
solution or a point along the solution
now say if we were to use it an
optimization as a you know guidance for
where they algorithm might start it
would be you know it would be a guess
for the for a part of the solution or a
component of the solution
well I think it's a really weird option
initial guess but it it's really weird I
mean but setting it up as an option is
the right thing to do the only question
is what the right name is and I think
you were trying to avoid the word
initial because it sounds like it's an
initial value problem yes well we could
we could have starting guests as well
but it's you know it goes back to the
question of what your we want to you
know we want we want something in there
to indicate that it's it's just you know
started that I mean in in optimization
libraries and stuff they typically call
this this thing a warm start oh yeah
hint he actually thought of that Oliver
objected strenuously to hint I know but
the exact reasons he he had okay but I
think that that is sort of what it is
let's find out what objections he had to
that okay let me let me dick to my some
some initial guess initial hint solution
hint yeah but that's why I was asking as
always solution at mine rioting right
right something like this is gonna work
you can set it up with a with a name
there why don't we use hmm initial try
try guess I don't know conjecture
okay well share Oliver's objections okay
I'll just read them to you you know he
says hint is not a terminology used
numerix also the starting vector is an
integral part of the algorithm hint is
not an integral part of the solution I
disagree with him on that bit point is a
hint is something one can give but we
were looking for something that must be
specified he's not really correct on
that I mean they his point is the
algorithm requires this to start which
is correct but the user doesn't have to
give that
and then his other objections are that
you know other PDE solvers use things
like start vector initial battle yeah
yeah but oh I'm beginning to I mean look
I'm beginning to admit that starting
guess as an option maybe at least
horrible alternatives just half that we
went yeah I'm fine with starting gas I
mean there's the initial versus starting
there's null
yeah I think I think starting is mildly
better all right let's go for starting
guess but I wouldn't mind picking this
up again um you know there's people on
live stream is suggesting things like
site values and values try first
yeah I mean starting try I don't think
try really helps because it's actually
something you're you are it's not a try
as in it's not like trying to find I
mean it's not like it's going to solve
the equation right that's another issue
with guess because guess doesn't in fact
solve the equation I think that's why
I'm that's my visceral objection to it
is that it doesn't guess suggests that
you know you've got some random definite
an equation and you can guess the
solution that's not what's going on here
this is something that's being fed into
numerical algorithm that it's the
beginning the starting point right well
one other possibility may might be
something like starting starting iterate
or something like that as because these
are typically always used in some kind
of iterative algorithm that that
corrects and improves
yeah well that seems better look guess
isn't right for the reason I just said
um what is that background it's driving
me crazy I'm sorry I'm just I was sorry
I was writing myself a note
I guess my desk is noisy Oh must be
something different I think starting it
er it wouldn't be horrible what are you
suggesting starting it to rate tour
starting iterate no nobody will know
what the heck that means um to be
thought about a little bit more okay
get something and we need to talk about
the next day or so okay put inputting
starting guess for now but we're gonna
change it well put it in as an option
for now definitely is an option yes okay
okay all right I think that's everything
Steven okay great
all right oh wait a minute should we yes
Rob should be covered fine fit and what
does that a cover that I'm really late
for something else right we don't need
to we can if we have one more we can
well there's not so much it's fit that
changes the most fit new good new lower
case new yeah no capital kennel hey
actually this
good suggestion for my livestream
initial seed values I like the concept
of a seed that's not too bad yeah the
problem is that that implies I the
problem I see with that as implies
randomness no it doesn't no I don't
think it does I mean I guess it's no
more random that a guess true yeah
initial seed values or why why do we
even need initial then why not just seed
values that's what but actually it's not
even values because its relations right
I mean what it really is is something
like seed conditions it makes one sound
like it's it's some planting a dicot or
something I like the idea of seed seed
is better than a um because it is it's
something that things are gonna grow
from in a somewhat undefined way also
suggestion on the live stream for
initial nudge but I don't think that's
right because nudge suggests you're
pushing in a certain direction which
this is not
I think seed is the right concept
starting seed how about so we have
random seeding right what about
initial seeding and then you say initial
seeding as X is six that's fine I'm
reasonably happy with that thank you to
wild animal channel who suggested the
seed idea um alright so do we want
another meeting on this or should we
just do that do that for now I think we
should have another meeting just to
finish off whatever you needed to finish
off here with okay thanks great stuff
thank you to folks on the livestream
thanks for those suggestions all right
it's driving me nuts okay I'm gonna be
happy to get off the slide this we are
going to for those on the live stream if
you're interested we are working on
chemistry next and just a moment